[Applause]
you begin our challenge I think this is
the longest I ever been at an airport
here at LAX art White has been for phone
how many times I'm having four or five
and throughout the week leading up to
the flight it was like pushed back took
an hour and yeah now we're actually here
it's in perspective another hour but
regardless of that we actually showed up
to the airport really really early I
think we were so excited to show that
were like we gotta get there early we
don't want to be late I wanna miss the
flight
and it'll try out four hours early well
it was three hours really from this time
that we thought we were going to depart
and then they delayed it some more so
yeah I guess closer to four hours early
[Music]
I dare you break that clean vibe up
[Music]
don't drop it don't drop it
he's also Hey oh you're aggressive you
know of yogurt yogurt spinner
[Music]
you're so aggressive I'm over here with
my spoon like you're trying to catch it
oh no and it wasn't you I know
dang it I'll have a napkin thank you
[Music]
[Music]
today we are at the airport to go to
Paris and Frick
it's our first turn I know it's our very
first time going to France you want to
tell them why we're going to Paris
because they are going to meet the
wedding planner in the Paris is these
two people are going to get married in
the Paris so we are on our way now to
Paris do you guys remember the vlog the
Christmas vlog when Casey gave me Paris
tickets as a surprise Christmas present
this is a trip and so now we're going
and we get to ten hour wedding and it's
just going to be a really fun and
memorable trip why are you doing it
can't we have a able to experience this
for the first time with Casey and with
Isaac and we came parents so we're going
to be meeting in Paris once we get there
I'm so excited I can't wait I can't wait
[Music]
dear friend you know everywhere I look
there's something French is like macaron
oh I want something let's say food near
buying or in French no I wasn't planning
on getting the Eiffel Tower I just saw a
really cute necklace I like know the
only 15 bucks what sue me cool I had
everything ingame growing up isn't it
funny I had everything Jing ings and I
ended up with an Asian guy and then my
dad loves uh McCracken everything Latin
isn't that funny as my dad was obsessive
Asian culture he had the stress balls he
had incense everywhere he would drink
the ginseng like the one with a little
warm in it or when I died or even oh
yeah I don't know he would drink that he
loved everything Asian brick house
creaking my Harry kick-ups whoa torn we
go can't control it about my dream oh
babe first I was trying to steal words
epic I just devastated right now
litigator you can't get really tense how
how did you demonstrate for me he tries
to take it out I can't say it go away
energy goes away alright so we prepped
Isaac for this trip because he has never
experienced panhandling like it happens
in Europe we went to Italy a couple
years ago so I got to see it firsthand
I've never been to Europe reports but
they're aggressive they're like they're
in your face we try to get you to give
them money give you bracelets for you to
wear on and then they hound you for
money or they try to like distract
you're doing something on one place and
then next thing you know they're they're
robbing out of your pocket or your purse
or whatever like they're just it's
really really really sketchy in Europe
and really dangerous if you're not
careful you could easily get
pickpocketed so we kind of prepped him
for all of this but now he's talking
about him demonstrating him practicing
trying to get pickpocketed because we
got these new backpack where these
backpacks are anti-theft backpacks so it
has a zipper on the inside and it's like
flash proof and waterproof and all these
things there's like these three great
compartments that the pocketers wouldn't
know about the exhibits they have the
zippers on the inside that's pretty cool
anyway
you can have that one week not for
school it's too big for you you can have
it for travel what is that victory dance
is watchable watch a lot I mean you are
in on the real moonwalk the real
Merlotte I mean do a moon jump
[Music]
any flow yeah literally now finally
reporting it's been like 180 10 hours
pretty specific for Adsense
[Music]
fresh fresh you know my cousin lives
here which I forgot to mention for you
guys I'm really really excited to my
cousin's event though she's been living
here for I think two years now I'm
excited to see her so we're probably not
going to see her til three days we're
going to be busy with wedding planning
on her being so because we've prepped
Isaac about all the fifth pocketers and
everything like changer to compete soon
as we landed he's like not letting go of
our hands the perfect it was good good
thank you scared to attorneys agree
because I'll be home safe so after Casey
gets the luggage we're going to go meet
mama and papa can and I miss him so much
I'm so excited to see them I see your
mom and ready let's do it
this is nice I lift my bangs I have my
two boys now I'm the cameraman
production assistant as a motive yes
okay I become the biggest biggest
imagine we've just been traveling alone
Isaac you want to travel alone camera
yeah you Kara
yeah baby big plunger oh yeah we're
getting a lesson in French stroke away
from our taxi driver you get would you
learn Isaac oh I say excuse me I'm
running
somebody must end that's Japanese
layer around disclaimers what do you see
you can see a typical the apple tarts
anymore I got a lot like Bigfoot's in
you know we finally got a friend to live
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness oh nice very nice
[Music]
oh my god why are you yeah how are you
crying already
this is so important I can't believe I'm
here I can't believe I'm seeing it with
my own eyes alright we have touched down
in Paris and we finally got to our
Airbnb you is it actually made me
teary-eyed today seeing that first time
- Leona is so so cute though it is like
everywhere we travel I get to like see
the inner child in you I can never live
that little girl inside of you guys like
she's thriving inside of me right now to
see that with my own eyes it's like
right between me is just that I can't
I'm still processing everything okay so
does it feel to be back in Paris with
your fiance planning your way me my
parents we came here about like six five
years ago and I told him at that time
this before TIFF and I actually started
dating uh saying yeah I kind of wish to
you know had a girlfriend that I could
bring out here because so romantic you
know and who would have known six years
later here we are I and five years later
I don't know I don't think something
interesting about that trip though you
sent me a message on facebook I did and
that was the very first interaction I
guess that really sets our relationship
or jewelry exacta we didn't talk before
this particular message at that and and
it's so funny that I sent two volunteers
he isn't sending these really long
message pretty much saying something
along the lines of like you know you
have a having an amazing smile I would
love to use you and some of my future
work and then
know that we took on vlogging five years
later together and I am utilizing yours
much more real quick every bad smell I
like see your and every single one of my
videos I know isn't that crazy like
think about itself we were actually
trying to think about like okay well
besides Paris being such a romantic city
why else are we getting married here
I'll exercise that and then I start
remembering I'm like wait we have a
closer connection to Paris because you
were here when you first sent me that
first message so that was a very special
message in a very special place and now
we're planning our wedding here oh my
god it's so cool mmm yay okay now it's
our first kiss and Kurt ha was it
because my parents are behind it I got
your more romantic this is this romantic
right here okay close your eyes good you
don't wanna do hello
[Music]
[Applause]
so it look like that lighting up it's
lighting up
okay so we're all settled in here now
we're going to go try to find some
dinner and just side note shout out to
my impression vanity because they gave
us this ring light here and so that's
how we have like p.m. oh look how
closely okay I'm just really all the
silhouette looks cool - oh let's do a
kitchen shower real quick so like
[Music]
and you've never seen you like this
wanting to be so romantic on it is Paris
hurts
it sets the tone oh you're out in about
this friend alright so we totally made a
mistake of not trying to brush up on
French even basic French like next ebook
cool ha ha ha
I put them what I know how to say I
don't smell June the Sun but I know how
to describe art that you can't ascribe
at all Janice aquatic oh gosh Hanover
here
[Music]
I'm a big fan of eating good food I love
peace but also love dog panic jealous
that my dad got duck and I overlooked
the menu exists see the duck on the menu
don't worry somewhere I don't want to
worry my dad does me felis yes I do love
someone a little like what I might have
done
oh come on hallo everybody here right so
we see you know it's nice to do you
happy peaceful isn't it sorcery - yeah
I'm trying to cross Cheers
I don't know how to do it in French
let's prompt German - true
we ordered creme brulee we're goanna
brand frog leg can you see the latest we
ran through leg and you want to do the
honors one
[Music]
your first time secret rulers yeah or
soup of the Turner and the fun oh
never Kimberly Bon Appetit
[Music]
and how thinner really good early headed
Jeanette arson trash Ryan right that
place is a great the intersection I
would ever want to drive that let's walk
more courts they're ready let's go there
we go now we will never write anything
that's the biggest a factory in the day
and be able to go up to the top I think
I think I think I think I think with our
cars go by
[Music]
yay go do you see I don't know where
we're going at it somehow so today's our
first full day in Paris and our
beautiful wedding center and is here she
took this morning our wedding is finally
coming to fruition a lot of planning a
lot of talking a lot a lot more talking
than actual planning the Fidesz
recommend yeah